this is the video this is the danger
miss me loud hum didn't last Salaam
alaikum peace be with you I'm Eddie your
host and you made it for another week of
the Dean show and in the studio this
week is a man with a lot of experience
he's in town and we want to talk to him
we want to pick his brain we want to
discuss family life many of us have
families thinking about having families
and we want to be able to keep them
together while many families are
breaking apart we want to give some
advice so we can keep those families
that maybe are on the verge of breaking
apart we can keep them together and give
some advice for those that are going
good where they can not and how they
cannot go wrong so when we come back we
got a surprise for you in the Dean show
studio I reveal that when we come back
here on the Dean shop this is the theme
the biju
this is the thesis but angel
this is the venue this is the things the
15 jus this is the days
Salaam alaikum peace be with you thank
you see I wanted to keep the surprise
Sheikh Mohammed Sade oddly is that right
yes Emma see now you one of the first
here in the Americas know you've been
here for a long time how long you been
an imam in in the United State well 40
50 years no not close to 40 plus but 40
plus years but I've been 33 years now
approximately doing the same work at
hamdulillah and the surprise that not
only doing the same work I've been the
Imam in my location the last location
since nineteen eighty nineteen eighty
the Imam and the director of the islamic
center of columbia south carolina well
it's a pleasure it's been a long time
you were we haven't had you on a Dean
show for quite some time so pleasure to
have you back thank you and glad to be
here is my pleasure dolls now you know
we cater to a lot of non-muslims and
that's our audience we're broadcasting
out of Chicago and people tune in and
before we want to break some ice do you
mind and I know you you're laid back
gentlemen Imam chick so for the not yet
Muslims are tuned in and they see the
beard and they say you know what they
just walked Fox News and they turn is
they said that's the guy look me but me
they might hook you up with somebody
from Afghanistan or then Laden this dan
the other what do you got to say it's
fine I'm a Muslim and I'm proud to be a
Muslim and this is part of the way how a
Muslim supposed to look all right maybe
some of it it recommended some of them
is must like groans a beer it's part of
our Dean I'm not embarrassed to say I'm
a Muslim and I have the honor to grow my
beard to try to imitate the prophets of
allah salaam marina Kofi were in a soap
okay does not mean i'm on every muslim
have to wear a soul but it's better they
distinguish himself to be a piece of
that one invitation for others because
if you are in the middle of the air
or and you don't know what you get to
you go to a voice and has something say
information so when somebody see you in
the train walking the street he will
know that you are a Muslim he would be
ready to approach you ask you about
Islam instead of seeing somebody else
with a suit and tie I'm not saying
something wrong with the certain time
but he's going to maybe have five
percent idea maybe you are a Muslim but
somebody will see me you will have
ninety-nine point nine percent this is a
Muslim I can ask him about Islam ok now
the numbers I'm not be lettin ya so now
when someone comes up to you and says
you know what they they come up to you
and they see you and they say you know
what that's a Muslim I want to come
straight to him and I'm sure you get a
lot of not much not yet Muslims
non-muslims will come up to you and this
one in particular says you know what
does your religion teach that you gotta
have the Jews or Christians accept Islam
or you kill them okay is this what your
religion teaches no we don't we have
something in Islam kool let kraja fede
you could not force anybody to accept is
a religion but we are commanded to give
dau we invite the people we care for
them because our d in telling us who so
ever dies without accepting wellness of
Almighty God and the finality of the
Prophet Muhammad Sal Allahu Allah he
will be among the dwellers of hellfire
so when I'm giving them Dawa talking to
them communicating to them dialogue in
with him is because I have love for them
I care for them and I wants mercy and
blessing to happen to them now if you
were living during the time of Jesus
Jesus peace be upon us before we believe
so long was one of the mightiest
messengers of God is this correct yes so
now if we were living during his reign
his prophethood did you have to accept
him as the messenger valance and the
oneness of God otherwise you're going to
be in some deep trouble exactly exactly
the same thing of course the same saying
that what was the Prophet Muslim Prophet
Abraham you have to submit yourself to
the will of god that means accept
almighty the creator as the only deity
to worship
and accept and acknowledge the messenger
that is in that his ear for you okay so
with that said now denying the prophet
muhammad sallallahu since he already
came denies the prophet muhammad
sallallahu ala meaning denying Jesus
also and not in Moses and denying Jesus
and Moses as you deny the Creator is the
choice that he send elasta profit so you
deny him that mean he denies the command
of God so if we say we don't believe in
Jesus we don't love and revere Jesus
then we're not Muslim know where I'm not
most this is a fact but we believe in
Jesus as a prophet of mighty God as the
messenger of a mighty God not as a son
of God not a part of God not equal to
God not the third of three this is yes
who believe in Jesus Messenger of Allah
prophet of Allah born from the Virgin
Mary ok that he has no father he has a
mother that he's assigned a miracle that
God Almighty send him and reveal to him
this hour believe about Jesus we love
him and we believe is the second coming
of Jesus this amazes another topic in
itself we want to get into the main
topic family life ok we want to talk
about what I had mentioned earlier in
the show that you know many it's a high
statistic people are getting married to
get divorced people are getting married
and you know what they're having a hard
time keeping the marriage together so in
general what advice would you give for
the husband and wife to be able to work
because you have a lot of experience i'm
sure in the 40-plus years you've had a
lot of sit downs or couples this right
of course yeah so what's like the number
one problem what's the dumbest what
what's the nut almost every day yes
what's the number one problem that
people come to you to complain husband
or wife huh it's different types of
problems but you see first of all before
i discuss this issue about problems and
family life and things like this there
is a quotation that some muslims believe
that to be saying of the prophet and is
very important clear
files to the less nervous special the
muslims in nevada halala hit a lob the
most helpful thing to allah which is
love for a divorce this not a quotation
or a statement of the prophet salallahu
does not mean we say islam teaches you
or encourage you to divorce your wife
but attaching this statement to the
Prophet this is not correct this is
something i would like to start with
okay and I think that we if I is it is
not an authentic or a system it's not
authentic oh no it's not authentic okay
but Islam doesn't forbid divorce at the
same time Islam doesn't encourage
divorce so we are not saying regardless
whatever happened between anza husband
even if they about to shoot each other
in the head I don't know sometimes it
shootings age sometimes you just this is
all over the news you hear like we here
okay but it's not Islam say no when it
comes to this you understand is better
that everybody go to his way and even
depart in the good way in good way so
Islam allows divorce f zs e needs for
divorce but the statement is not correct
but let's go to the problem the problem
is start with while you're going to
marry this woman who want you out of
choosing this man let's hold off right
there we're gonna take a break when we
write back with the answer this question
here on nadeesha Islam is the fastest
growing religion in the world and most
of the converts are women not men they
see that the rules of Islam instead of
constraining it the rules set them free
this is the video this is the thesis
teen jou OU can you put your dream home
and you've got your dream car but you're
going to get old and things are going to
happen to you in your life and then what
have you got at the end of the day is an
empty dream that has no real foundation
we are gonna die and we're gonna meet
our Lord and he is going to judge us it
becomes an obligation for each single
human being to find out what the Quran
is Islam is telling us to stay away from
things which are bad for your person in
bed for the society it's killing of
innocent human beings human life is
precious back here in the Dean show with
imam Sheikh Mohammed said ugly so before
we left off you talked about a common
quotation that's attributed to the last
and final messenger peace be upon
numbers he said this is not authentic
yes how about the one that says that the
throne of Allah shakes at the happening
of divorce it's not authentic and we
shouldn t understand adding things to
the Dean or lying again is the prophet
salallahu lab to stop a problem so much
this is a crime itself but you talk
about Allah and His Messenger with some
things he didn't say yeah but now if
someone says well how do you know it's
not authentic how does somebody verify
that now what you're saying is correct
because there is a way to authenticate
any statement said by the prophets allah
la selling it have a scientists have a
way of study you have a scholar they
spend same thing like somebody giving
you gold or silver and you could not
yourself know if it's gold or silver so
you take it to people who specialize in
this field they examine it they make
some experiments and tell you according
the testing in the lab this shows that
this is gold but is 19 carrots this 22
carats like this yeah so the same thing
in hadith there is people who specialize
and stolen of knowledge like myself you
understand we go and utter what is the
scanner saying this is not my speciality
but I at least I have the
that they can go open the books and
search who said authentic or not
authentic and these people are not
making their own idea they make a study
they make a test and to understand is
this been narrated authentic from the
prophets allah allah allah or is it as a
break in the chain of his Ned the
communication I told you you told him
you told her she told him he heard from
the Prophet Ord are these week or these
totally not authentic or not the first
one about abroad LOLOL Allah is not
presenting about the throne of metal are
shaken is fabricated okay okay so let's
continue on and people can go verify
this and check this of course okay so
now tell us now what's the number one
complaint that you get from people who
come to see you in your office okay but
the people always have the complaint but
what I'm saying is the problem is
started from day one when you're that
when you blend it to get into
relationship with a woman or a woman
getting in a relationship with a man to
be a husband to be a wife what is what
is the main thing you like about this
man or this woman that you want to marry
because when we did not come as the
prophet salallahu LM saying what the
meaning is a man seeks marriage from a
woman for one of these reasons okay
don't tell Mara larva lamellae hell has
a behind jamali a further forbidden
terabithia dead Oh comical as a la la
sala that immense six marriage from a
woman because one of this quality her
beauty her wealth her family lineage
lineage okay or because her belief
religion so the prophets say marry a
woman because hair relation otherwise
you be a loser so you start in a
building with no solid foundation
because is the Dean is the religion is
the teaching of Quran and the authentic
zone is what is going to be the solution
to our problems but if we marry I won't
become a man because his handsome or
because I understand he rage or a woman
because this and these things comes and
goes so when you try to apply
the medicine to it which is the teaching
of al-islam you are not ready to take
this medicine you have you have some
kind of what you call alergy again is it
you could not take this medicine yes so
we need to stablish something in the
beginning why I'm going to marry this
woman or why this woman going to marry
this man so once we acknowledge okay
let's say that the person married
someone who is a righteous person they
live by the total complete submission
and surrendering acquiring piece from
the one guy of the Creator Islam and
they live by the Quran which is the rate
of word of god and the authentic
teachings of the last and final
messenger his Sunnah the hadith peace be
upon him so now these people who did
that and now they're still might having
some issues okay because a human being
now you're having getting to people with
different habits with different ideas
with different views and you want to put
both of them together not for a couple
of hours they're going to be day and
night in faith in each other face yeah
so we have to grow in understanding the
personality of each other we need to
learn how to accommodate each other and
this is a problem sometimes they
understand that in the family okay the
man want to be the leader you want to be
there the chief he want this is fine he
has his right okay but he doesn't know
how to be a man how to be a boss how to
manage things and the woman also want to
maybe grab the same steering wheel and
to be the one who ran the issues in the
distance there is something called
consultation I don't have to go by what
my wife saying but can at least ask her
opinion what you think about it and we
are not going to discuss things about
I'm going to pray zuhr afternoon prayer
for a cat or three ricarte we don't make
consultation about it but if you want to
understand to to go out for outing you
and your wife and the children instead
of okay this where we're going to this
weekend can we consult camel discuss it
as example
maybe she have another reference II
understand or some other idea she would
like to go to the zoo Lisa the park as
example so we have to learn how to
manage how to understand the other the
other person to be in the other person
show this one of the problems that we
don't know how to accommodate each other
communication is key of course okay
consultation and communication now
consultation between each other but if
it excels let's say that they're not
seeing eye-to-eye okay mother Lodge
father-in-law should they take it to
their families will this bring more harm
or good when the say the wife she starts
to okay come mother-in-law and
father-in-law because you want to take
it your mother your mother loves you
more than here yeah this is nature okay
she take it to her mother her mother
loves their baby more than you so
everybody they're interested in is there
a child so they are not going to bring
so even the Islam teaching of this fab a
so how come I mean Ali had hakama mean
anyway ha commandant any when it comes
about is going to be a clash and divorce
and all this methodology is not working
Allah said bring a person from her
family as representative and a person
from his family and they sit down in a
family gathering discussing the problem
you see but I could not be always
calling my mother and she's calling her
mother and everybody getting a different
views they need to sit in a family
gathering and they try to listen and
they try to see what is the best for the
family this what it have to be so we
have to sometimes but also i don't see
that this is the solution unless that
everything else it didn't wear why we
couldn't finish this down this is this
is the last like final straw exactly
okay so why a husband and wife could not
sit down and talk to each other first
why you could not be patient with one
another and listen the problem and the
sense that we don't want a lesson and
this brings a serious problem
so sometimes is matter of lending a ear
to your partner and for some reason some
people did not won't do it out of
arrogancy out of feeling I'm to God but
lots the prophet salallahu selim we have
to always see how the prophet salallahu
so patient and he was there tried to
solve the problem as example the Hadees
is saying was the meaning is my foyer
Rasool Allah hisilani miss Allenby no
I'm Brian in la terre isayama never the
prophets of allah salam being given a
choice between two mothers this Ozzy you
want to eat under check in or you want
to eat beef you want to go to the door
you want to go to the bar as long as not
hella and haram so the prophet used to
what use the easier so let it go hey
honey what you would like to go this
weekend no I don't like a regular buster
what do you like I like seafood okay
it's not a big deal all right but
clashing comes out of nothing why
because we don't know how to let it go
sometimes or how to discuss things or
try to see what as long as not something
Haram try to compromise and if you try
to compromise to make your wife heavy
believe me she will see it even if she
did not see it later on when she got
sleep next day she would think about and
maybe she tried to compete with you next
time she will try to compromise for you
for the next time so we have to know how
how to to blaze this role of being a
involved as one team we r 1 t1 team
exactly okay one team let take a break
and we'll come back one team the energy
shot
they're always be someone there will be
there to say something negative but at
the same time there'll be someone there
to say something positive awesome just
hold on to the Rope of Allah everything
in this universe rely I need a last
minute the Quran says don't kill women
don't kill children don't feel old
people don't attack the civilians this
is what the Prophet Muhammad told us it
will fail you mock you know veloci that
the Prophet SAW shall have never ever
start a war against any of us and if
we're going to worship something I
figured I might as well worship the
Creator instead of any of the creations
now in upon investigating the villages I
remember finding out the meaning of what
Islam is what Muslim is those who
surrender yourself to God is a Muslim
those who surrender submit to God God's
will Daisy Islam was pure it was just
you just pray to God you create back
here on the Dean show we're talking
about one team on the run rough one
family saying we want to keep the
families together so they got roles to
play can you briefly tell us what's the
man's role the woman's role because
sometimes these roles get mixed up okay
first of all we have to understand what
we get married okay and we have to
understand that we have a goal we are
trying to create a new unit to worship
Allah so our marriage is alize towards a
higher goal and we have to learn how to
sacrifice to reach our goal people come
from overseas to America to learn
English and depart from their families
and other things because they have a
ball we have a higher goal to please
Allah to go to Jenni so and it's going
to be obstacles it's going to be
problems but we have to learn how to
sacrifice how to be patient so our goal
is bleeding Allah raising a Muslim
family how I be as a husband protection
for my wife and my wife be protection
for me not only for economic reason only
okay but we have to be it means my wife
is a means for me to help me to love my
gays
protect my private parts okay and I am
also the same for here you see so you
scratch my back I scratch your back you
got to protect me i'm going to see you
so this is one thing and also we want to
be a leader to lead little kids okay or
little children to raise them as Muslims
to do the right thing and they stay away
from what's forbidden this is something
have to be also exist in our mind and
always because the goal will go to make
a sacrifice if we're not go to learn is
this we are not going to be we we are
one team what is the role of the man and
a woman is simple you have a basket or a
bucket has two years okay you have a box
you carry from this side I care from the
side otherwise if I carried my by myself
I'm going to break my back I'm going to
help my muscles so now you carry from
one side she cared from one side so now
there is two things needs to be done
here somebody you have to earn as a
dollar to bring food income to the house
and somebody have to keep the house
running and watches the children so now
let's split let's split the
responsibility and of course by nature
by all means Allah made the man suitable
to go outside to search for the dollar
and they suffer and hard of this that
sensing element a woman with a gentle
and kind heart and have more patient to
deal with the children and how to make
the place as a paradise and haven for
her husband so her job is not more
important than mine neither my job is
more important than hey both of us try
to serve to be to have one team we have
one umbrella we have one thing and all
of us going to be under it ok so both of
us have to be like one hand washes the
other wait one just like there's only
one gasps of course maybe have to be one
team you could not you could not have
two people drive in one car ok you want
to drive I'm going to be the best injure
or I'm going to be the best you got to
drive you choose and since I already
take the course of
going to understand how to drive I'm
going to drive God Almighty Allah our
creator gave me the responsibility and
said I remeasure loca hormonal and he
said they may Allah Adam alibi or be man
and [ __ ] women Imani so Allah design you
for a second job and Allah design here
for a second job we're going to accept
the choice of allah aur woh going to
make our only choice so lessening
adhering to the command of Allah is
something very important and it's going
to be obstacles and ups and down but we
have to work on it sit down talk give
each other ear you understand trying to
consider the other person try to have
their feeling see what they complain try
to consider you see this is something
very important try to listen to your
partner always try to listen to your
pardon try to give them it secures why
they did this gives them another excuse
try to forgive there is many things that
we can talk about it how to keep this we
don't want to split it we don't want to
cut it off we don't want it disperses I
on it we want to keep it almost and tell
you going to die or she's going to die
and both of us we want to meet again in
general in sha allah thank you for the
incredible great advice oh thank you
thank you and shala we look forward to
having you back again and a voice like
God will inshallah and some great advice
communicate work together to keep the
family together under one roof one
family worshipping the one God and this
is what Islam is really focusing on all
of us to do to form a relationship with
the one Creator who created this whole
universe and everything in it and to
come together man and woman as a family
husband and wife working together
collaborating together in goodness so
they can have righteous children and
those children can go out and contribute
to make a righteous society we look
forward to having you back here with us
here on the Dean show do not forget to
pick up the Dean show dvds and share
this message of peace peace acquired by
submitting yourself entirely to the One
God Islam share this message you can get
our dvds at DVD for Dawa com you can
copy them give them out to the non most
and don't forget to visit us here every
week on the Dean show until then next
time peace be unto you